ladies and gentlemen the one piece live
action now I have just finished binging
all eight episodes of it starting
seconds after it came out and even
though I swore to myself that I would
get some sleep first and then share my
thoughts about it with all of you in the
morning
I should have known that that was just
not going to happen now we do need to
talk about this show and if it ended up
being another letdown proving that live
action just does not work for anime or
if it somehow actually managed to live
up to its hype and break the curse once
and for all but of course if you haven't
seen all eight episodes yet you have
hereby been spoiler warned and we begin
with the very first episode arguably the
most important one because I mean if you
don't like the pilot you're probably not
going to keep watching right so how did
it do I think right off the bat with the
very first opening sequence I personally
let out a little bit of a sigh a sigh of
relief if you want and even though there
was still a lot to come I knew that at
least visually and music wise this was
not going to suck which with all things
that might still go wrong was a very
important win I think really fantastic
animation here right into that beautiful
long drone shot straight into loketown
where of course we kick things off with
the execution of Goldie Roger just like
in the Mangan anime and actually GARP
blasting at me in a thick Scottish
accent was not exactly what I had on my
bingo cards right out of the gate and I
did not expect how big of a role his
character would actually be playing in
this series of course we did already see
a lot of the sequins in the trailer but
there's still a few things that stood
out to me right off the bat first of all
thank God that they fixed the color
grading of the entire show by the way
like in the trailers everything still
looks very clean fake but clearly there
was still a lot of post-production and
polishing going on behind the scenes
because the entire show now had a really
nice desaturated look with a lot of
character and they clearly also added
some sort of smoke fog and other visual
elements to kind of connect everything
in frame together and actually this was
kind of one of my biggest fears going
into the show and they luckily ended up
nailing it also in this scene
particularly but also throughout the
entire series The Mew music was just on
point a lot of tracks obviously inspired
by and mixed with the official one-piece
score for example we hear Bing sake
during Luffy's flashback with Shanks but
also a bunch of original music that
still was very nicely inspired by the
characters that they included for
example a jazzy french-like tune
liberatier or the Spanish theme in the
scene with mihawk it's kind of a little
nod to him being based on a Spanish
conquistador but anyways what also
became a very clear within like the
first three minutes of watching The One
Piece live action is brutal like what
the like just the first episode alone we
get Roger being executed pretty
gruesomely there I say alvida crushing
someone's head with her club and Zar
just straight up cutting the Baroque
Works agent Mr Seven in half which then
overall kind of leads to this General
really strange mix of gory seriousness
but also this light-hearted comedy with
the look of the many quirky characters
in one piece that we know and love when
which kind of feels bizarre but honestly
it's just exactly what I personally have
been hoping for keeping the series fun
side but also still appealing to an
adult audience and making things a
little bit more mature though didn't
quite expect things to go up as mature
as full on new Tel mepo playing with his
sword okay but but going back to the
fights the battles and choreographies
throughout the series were also insanely
well done highlight for me personally
being sanjis and zoro's team up in the
last episode and of course the perfect
copy from the anime of Zoros and
mihawk's fight and actually speaking of
visual elements the special effects in
the show were really spectacular at some
points buggy CGI and that of the Sea
King were insanely well done and just
overall there was a really nice mix and
balance between physical and digital
effects being used two notable
exceptions to this though that stood out
really weirdly where one Zorro swords
shattering after this clash with mihawk
only that it really looked like really
gruesomely bad CGI and the second time
was actually true catching fire in his
fight with Usopp where it kind of just
looks like they set up a mannequin and
set it on fire and then it suddenly just
kills over in the wrong directions in
fact in contrast to all the other
fantastic and Flawless effects up to
this point this scene with chu in
particular made me actually laugh out
loud for a second just for how much it
stood out to me and another thing that I
thought was consistently great
throughout the entire show were the
locations and Islands I mean loketown
just look insane Luffy's home fuchsia
Village looked perfect as well same goes
for the Marine base and syrup Village
and most importantly the show really
managed to bring these places to life
like this little safe here and the map
room inside Morgan's Marine base in the
first episode just really filling these
locations with life in my opinion and
really the only exception to this for me
was nami's Hometown kokoyashi Village in
the last two episodes because even
though all of these locations had a
unique and fresh take on them mommy's
Hometown kind of missed that feeling of
a small village in Paradise that
secretly is being tormented by arlong I
mean whatever this is is just a little
bit too rural for me but speaking of the
changes to the island in general you
probably also noticed that overall the
entire one piece world has been made a
little bit more modern in the show like
the party bar and Luffy's flashback has
Neon Lights electricity does seem to be
like just a regular thing in this
version of the one piece world and many
of the outfits in the series are also
just like straight out modern day
clothing now I'm personally a little bit
torn about this decision to just be
completely honest with you because on
the one hand I do really dig the overall
aesthetic that they were going here for
plus there actually is a large variety
of technological levels in the One Piece
manga as well but at the same time part
of the original story's charm for me is
that most places in the one piece world
are kind of stuck in a pre or maybe at
Max mid industrialization era where only
some unique places in the grand line
actually have access to any sort of
advanced technology with maybe the
exception of the world government who
actually uses their technological
advantage and knowledge to rule over the
rest of the world but again
aesthetically it is a really cool Take
On The World here and I can probably
roll with it and speaking of Luffy's
childhood flashback actually I have very
divided feelings here and I'll start
with the negative this time now I
personally don't really buy neither
Shanks nor his first made Ben Beckman
here for Ben Beckman nothing against the
actor but this is one of the very few
really bad castings in the show in my
opinion I mean this guy neither looks
nor feels like the tall chill and kind
of lean guy who we know from the story
as for sheng's I mean the actor Peter
gadiat actually I think looks quite a
lot like Shanks and also did a great job
portraying him it's just his costume I
guess was just kind of off like the
straw hat is just way too small and
doesn't look as worn and tauren as it
kind of should be after having been
passed down to him by Roger now of
course I did absolutely love Shanks
doing his finger gun towards the
mountain Bandit and then lakiru just
actually firing the shots that was
pretty cool to say the least also the
final scene with him and mihawk that
they perfectly copied from the anime it
was really nicely done as well and this
has nothing to do with Shanks per se but
the way that they showed his conquerors
hockey to shoo away the big sea king
it's kind of a little bit underwhelming
I've found I mean not sure if you get
that too I just think it could have used
a lot more power and gravity to it
visually but maybe also sound wise and
next to Shanks and Ben Beckman I
personally also found that the portrayal
of kid Luffy here just kind of missed
the mark by quite a bit honestly because
instead of being headstrong and a little
bit of a pest if we're being honest like
in the anime this version of Luffy is a
lot less cheerful and just came across a
little bit more like a crybaby though
let me know if you thought that it
worked for you I'd love to hear your
thoughts that being said though I do
personally think that the flashbacks
were actually one of the absolute best
parts of the entire season very much
unironically all of them were kept
extremely close to the raw materials and
all of them had at least the same level
of emotional impact as in the anime and
I'll be honest some of them even
surpassed the original for me I mean
seeing usob losing his mother again
while his dad is off partying with
Shanks actually made me tear up seeing
it happen to an actual child and sanji's
flashback with death was just insanely
dark and gruesome especially showing the
remaining blood and flesh on the rock
where zeph had actually cut off his lack
and eaten it and I mean uh oh my God
don't don't even get me started on
nami's one I mean yeah belmare looks a
little bit too old here I think and yes
they didn't straight out show her being
shot in the head by Arlon like they did
in the manga very openly but honestly it
was Heavy enough the way it was and so I
think most importantly all of these
flashbacks actually made me truly care
and empathize with this version of the
straw hats once again so it might not be
a big surprise for you when I tell you
that the backstories were actually one
of the most important things in the show
to get 100 correct for the author Ichiro
Oba and in fact I do think that most
characters in the show have been
portrayed pretty much perfectly I mean
mihawk helmeppo Kobe zef Nami Sanji usop
and of course we'll also get into the
villains in a moment as well also I will
admit that halfway through the first
episode by the way during the bar scene
here I did end up switching from English
to the Japanese dub which for me
personally made a ton of stuff work
really really really well throughout the
rest of the show that seemed to be a
little bit cringe at least from what I
could see from the English subtitles so
yeah having the actual voice actor of
everyone from the anime made the entire
thing incredibly enjoyable to me and
sold me a lot of scenes way more so than
the English original might have done so
but actually coming back to my list of
Perfect characters you might notice that
I didn't list two characters in
particular here Zorro and Luffy and
actually for Luffy it's really only some
minor things that bug me a little bit
here and there for one I just don't wipe
with some of the humor that they wrote
for him though some stuff was fairly
enough absolutely hilarious for example
his interactions with buggy pure gold
and similarly some of Luffy CGI stuff
was just a little bit meh like for
example him dodging alvida's Club here
in episode 1 while some other stuff like
his headbutt against poodle or of course
his gomugomo acts that took down arlong
and his Park were done exceptionally
well and so really maybe my biggest two
issues that I had with Luffy though were
once when he's actually captured in this
water tank by buggy where he apparently
is looking generally scared for his life
which is just not very Luffy like to me
and a second time when Zorro is
unconscious after being defeated by Miha
now before you say anything I personally
don't mind them showing how much Luffy
does care for his nakama after all he
really really does I mean we know that
but the way that Luffy behaves and kind
of overreacts here just doesn't seem
like something that the real Luffy would
do if you get what I'm saying other than
that though I'm more than happy to say
that iniaki Godoy did a great job
bringing the character to life that is
actually a character that's really
really hard to actually bring to life I
think and I'm also more than happy to
admit that often enough he just hit the
right tone in such a way that I just
couldn't help but catch myself grinning
over it which now brings me to maybe the
biggest criticism I have of the entire
show which is my favorite character in
the entire series roronoa Zorro and
first off to get it out of the way
visually the casting and costume of
Zorro are flawless no complaints here
but but oh boy does it go downhill from
there for me because to me this is not
Zorro that we're seeing here but someone
maybe cosplaying Zorro but they would be
like now to be clear I don't really know
if this is to blame on the writing staff
or on my kenyu's acting or maybe a
combination of both but this character
just feels like a really big
disappointing Miss to me and so let me
explain a little bit because the Zoro
that I and so many other people in the
world love and respect so much is
actually cool not because he says cool
things and doesn't cry it's because
Zorro is someone who believes so
strongly in his own strength but also in
his path that he has chosen as a
swordsman that he genuinely doesn't
really care what people he doesn't care
about think about him now that's cool
and when he actually does care it does
give his character just so much more
depth like crying after being defeated
by mihawk and swearing his loyalty to
Luffy the future pirate king and I mean
that scene in the live action was just a
complete shadow of the original in the
manga then of course in the original
Zoro is being rescued by Luffy last
second and decides to dedicate himself
to this goofy Captain here also scratch
completely from the live action Luffy
unties him then leaves again and then
they fight Morgan together in the manga
Zoro willingly lets himself be tied up
for a month by the way not a week to
protect a little girl and in the live
action yeah he does protect the girl and
then he just lets himself get tied up in
the yard for basically no reason at all
well also yeah Zoro in the anime is a
lot more ruthless than Luffy and is
willing to kill I guess but this sorrow
we get is just insane like just straight
up cutting people in half and he
actually says that he wants to kill
mihawk as if killing mihawk was
necessary to zoro's dream like I'm not
saying Zoro would never kill mihawk in
the manga but clearly his goal is to try
and beat him in a duel of skill to take
his title not by killing me Hawk so
really just the entire fire I don't
laugh because I'm too cool kind of thing
to me just feels like someone who's kind
of overflowing with insecurity and not
like the coolest character in the world
who doesn't care about anything except
his friends now his counterpart Sanji on
the other hand
no no pun intended the scenes with him
on the bharati and with zeph were
perfect and just like in the manga once
he actually joins up with the crew his
chemistry with the rest of the straw
hats is just off the charts which now
actually brings me to the other big
thing that will be so so controversial
about this adaptation I think and that's
that they did end up changing a lot and
I mean a lot more than I ever had
anticipated we get more buggy who was
without any doubt to me these standout
performance of this season incredibly
well done first making him terrifying
and then giving him this comedic twist
that we really all wanted but then
there's also a bunch of stuff that I
thought was not really necessary to
change and that just took away a bit
from my experience here and first off we
had not one but two entire episodes of a
kind of Freddy krueger-style teenage
horror thing inside the Mansion on syrup
Village I mean don't get me wrong Kudo
was portrayed fantastically I think but
I do think that this entire syrup
Village Arc could have probably been
done with in like 30 minutes not 120.
also instead of usop actually saving his
village and being a hero he does nothing
in his own arc here instead Nami and
Kaya kind of get all the emotional parts
and even though Zorro does get a great
flashback like everyone else it was
really weirdly placed in like a
30-minute strangely overly dramatic
battle trying to climb out of a hole you
know instead of saving this flashback
for when it actually makes sense like
with his clash with mihawk you know
whatever also I feel like the show
really missed out on building some real
suspense and mystery for the audience at
times like for example even without
knowing anything about one piece it was
so obvious that Kudo is the bad guy like
five minutes into the episode and
similarly later on NAMI betraying the
straw hats and revealing herself as part
of arlon's crew could be such a awesome
shock moment for more new fans and
instead it's kind of made painfully
obvious multiple times that she really
doesn't want to go before she then
actually leaves while also saving
Luffy's life and then also blaming him
for Zorro almost dying anyways the next
big change was of course to have arlong
and the fish men appear way way early in
the story which honestly I think worked
pretty well well had it not been for
that one weird fight between arlong and
Luffy at the baratier where he just
completely wiped the floor with Luffy
which cannon-wise ha and of course that
was the biggest change of all GARP being
the main Marine antagonist chasing Luffy
through the East blue and and while I
actually genuinely really liked this
idea as a concept basically kind of
taking garb's interaction with the straw
hats on water 7 and kind of weaving it
earlier into the story here the
execution of this entire thing was just
not that well done I think first off we
are meant to believe that Garb seriously
wants to capture Luffy but can't which
we know given how powerful Garb is would
be nope problem for him to do whatsoever
and then at the end it's kind of
supposed to have been all this twist and
a test to see if Luffy was ready so you
sent mihawk to capture Luffy as a test
what also neither of these make sense
for garb's character really I mean he's
not the type to actually try and capture
his grandson just see how he reacted
during Ace's execution at marineford but
he's also not exactly the type to make
sure that Luffy is ready to become the
next pirate king otherwise he actually
would have been there in the manga which
he wasn't so I did enjoy the Chemistry
Between the characters and seeing Garb
interact with characters like mihawk and
Zephyr with all that being said though
even though yes there was a bunch of
things to complain about with the one
piece live action in The Great scheme of
things as someone who was at first
extremely skeptical of this entire
project my expectations have been
honestly Blown Away even if it wasn't
perfect and despite my biggest fears
this show was actually really fun to
watch it really got me involved with its
characters and most importantly it
really felt like watching One Piece come
to life in a way it made me laugh it
made me cry and most importantly I
finished the last scene with a big grin
on my face also here's my list of
ratings for each episode overall
bringing the show to a really solid 7.5
out of 10 score for me I'm genuinely
really happy that my favorite series of
all time now has a new interpretation of
itself and I very much hope that there
will actually be a season two so we can
see how it goes on in the meantime
here's another video for you to watch
there's going to be more live action
content and uh yeah Shanks for watching
time to go to bed